Is what was legendary.
Here's literary work showed signs of brilliance and his lifestyle made him for a
time amongst the most celebrated artists,
so his age.
Yes,
his spectacular fall was unprecedented,
only equals in modern times by the disaster.
That was Oj Simpson.
Oh yes.
In this week's biographics,
we are diving into the Algebra righteous life of the self proclaimed genius
Oscar Wilde.
I'll skip and go flat out.
He Wills Wilde into the weld on October the 16th 1854 the flamboyance of his
name,
but was a portions of things to come.
His parents,
they were socially prominent Anglo Irish Protestants,
each where the collective interest say belief in national politics and take
publishing career of their own.
Oscar's father William was a renounced physician specializing in the eye and yet
he was a slight on campus to figure with an ugly beard and a roving eye,
but this absolutely did not stop him carrying on numerous affairs throughout his
marriage and he fathered several illegitimate children.
In contrast to our husband know Oscar's mother Jane was especially elegant and
statuesque.
She was almost six feet tall and towered over our husbands.
She was a woman who longed to make a sensation,
one stating that I should like to rage through life.
This Orthodox creeping is too tame for me as well.
You probably guessed that this was the attitude that that her son would quickly
embrace when Oscar and her second son was eight months old.
Jean described him as a great stout creature who minds nothing but growing fat.
Jane had actually wants to go in a set to have dressed Oscar and treated him as
a daughter for the first decade of his life.
That's age nine Oscar,
along with his older brother,
Willie,
was sent to his first score,
the Portora royal boarding school in Enniskillen foreign,
the Protestant north of Ireland's Oscar was younger than most of his peers,
though.
At first he was a clips by his older brother,
but by the time that Willie was set to leave Portora,
he had been superseded academically by Oscar.
In fact,
the younger Wilde was intellectually far ahead of his classmates in 1889 he
recalls,
I always looked upon as a prodigy by my associates because quite frequently I
would for a wager read a three volume novel in half an hour,
so please submit.
Used to be able to give an accurate resume of the plot of the story.
By one I was reading,
I was unable to give.
They fed a narrative of the incidental scenes and it's the most person in
dialogue.
In 1871 wild won a scholarship to study classics at Trinity College Dublin.
He arrived down in 1873 at the age of 18 there he was tutors and befriends is by
reverends.
John Pentlands,
Mahathey professor of ancient history.
Mahaffey inspired is be able to be proficient in Greek and in 1875 he won the
prestigious but lead gold metal in Greek.
Three years later in 1874 Oscar sale to England's take the examination for a
classic scholarship at Oxford University while awaiting the results,
he went to London and was dazzled by his first taste of the metropolis.
After that,
he traveled to a nother metropolis and that was Paris.
It was there with his mother and brother that he received news that he had won
his scholarship and had not only one it,
but it achieved the highest mark of the entire group,
Oscar,
that he absolutely made the most of his time at Oxford.
It was during this time that he cultivated his aesthetic sensibilities,
filling his room with lilies and spending vast portions of his father's money
upgrading the deck or of his room.
It was at this time that he famously said,
I find it harder and harder every day to live up to my blue China.
Whilst he was never a fan of sports,
but he did enjoy watching others play crickets and also run.
He developed a reputation for his wit proclaiming that the only possible
exercises to talk not to walk still,
he was absolutely no pushover.
It is believed that once while in his room for undergraduates pounced on him to
beat him up and smashes belongings while they said to have kicked out the first
interloper punched the second does,
he doubled over,
held the third through the end and it's carried the last back to his own room
and then tossed him on the floor.
Now it was during his time at Oxford that wilds became a mason.
He adopted the costume,
velvet breaches,
tailcoat white tie and silk hose that is extravagant lifestyle.
It was ultimately dented in April of 1876 when his father died.
Even a serious Das behinds Oscar though he still managed to find a way to
indulge himself with semester holidays around Europe just prior to his
graduation in 1878 he consult his mother destroy too with financial worry that
we have genius.
That is something attorneys can't take away.
Oscar the emerged from Oxford with a degree and a clear vision of what was in
store in a remarkably prophetic couple of sentences.
He declared,
God knows I won't be a dried up Oxford don anyhow.
I can also live without desire.
Fair and pain,
self poised,
self centered and self comforters are the a poet,
a writer,
a dramatist.
Somehow or other,
I'll be famous and if not famous,
notorious.
In December of 1878 wild moved to London,
he shared a flat with Frank Miles,
a fellow Oxford graduate.
During this time,
he was introduced to many writers,
artists and actors.
He gained a reputation for is where's it became a favorite dinner guest where he
would espouse his aesthetic values.
He applied for various fellowships and even trying to become an inspector of
schools.
During all of this,
he was working on his first play,
Vera,
which he privately printed in 1880 vera was a story of noble socialism set in
19th century Russia,
but it's unfortunately for Wilde's,
the New York and London producers that he sent the Plato.
They turned it down.
In 81 Oscar published 61 pieces of writing under the title poems and initial run
of 750 copies.
It's sold out with to further printing runs being requires.
Meanwhile,
during all of this,
a play by the renowned team of Gilbert and Sullivan was indirectly making wild
famous.
It was called patients and it was a lampoon if the aesthetic culture that wild
epitomized the main character was clearly model on him by June of 1881 wild
status which such that the Prince of Wales comments as I do not know Mr Wilde
and to not to know Mr Wales is not to be known.
Despite this ever growing reputation,
wild found himself in tough financial straits.
He was offered and accepted a series of lecture tours around America to coincide
with the New York opening of patients.
He set sail on Christmas Eve 1881 to instruct the new world in the English arts
of Renaissance.
On arrival he told the New York customs officer,
I have nothing to to clad.
That's my genius,
but don't try this today.
Anyone.
Well,
the Americans,
the were absolutely fascinated by him and the original schedule was to be
extended repeatedly in order to meet public demands.
It would last almost a year and it would even extend to Canada financially.
He did very,
very well out of this tall.
He actually stayed in New York for two months after the tours ends.
He then briefly returned to London in January of 1883 before relocating to Paris
where he immersed himself in artistic circles.
It was at this point that he made himself over physically.
He had his long flowing locks transformed into a bowl haircut and to took to
wearing a black overcoat.
This was increased contrast to the flamboyance colors that he was previously
known for in May of 1883 wild or returned to London,
apparently motivated by his interest in a woman named Constance Lloyd,
the daughter of a prosperous Lund and lawyer for the last few years.
Despite here's American earnings is Oscar have set and money worries,
variety.
Marriage would also solve those problems while also answering the growing gossip
about his sexual character.
A year long courtship followed with the marriage taking place on the 29th of
May,
1884 the couple they honeymooned in Paris and then thanks to his new father in
law's money occupied a four story house in London.
He then went ahead and had the place redecorated at huge expense,
which plunged the newlyweds into immediate debt.
Wild's first child Cyril was born on the 5th of June,
1885 with Vivian following on November the fifth 1886 with his writing career
going nowhere,
but he agreed to a British lecture tour with topics such as the value of art in
modern life,
lecturing and other invitations.
They kept him away from his family home a lot and during these long absences he
began to surround himself with young men writing undauntedly of his infatuation
with the beauty of the male form.
He formed an especially close friendship with a 17 year olds named Robbie Ross
during the late 1880
as well,
bringing in money with occasional book reviews at Wildworks on his first novel,
the picture of Dorian Gray when the book was published in a magazine in 1890 it
caused an immediate scandal,
the storyline and involved a subtly eroticize triangle of relationships between
three men and it was condemned by many as being immoral.
Whilst it predicted such an outcome to having written the following.
In the preface,
there is no such thing as a moral or immoral book.
Books are well written or badly written.
That is all it was around this time.
The wild was introduced to do a blondes basket and undergraduates by the name of
Lord Alfred Douglas,
but he was known to his intimate,
says Boise.
Oscar quickly became obsessed with a 22 year olds.
From this time on,
Oscar saw constants and his children less often.
He did writings from rented addresses or hotels usually with Boise and Tome
Boise's father was actually the marquis of Queensbury.
Yup.
The man who developed the rules of professional boxing.
He took an immediate and intense exception to the relationship between his son
and his,
the famous whiles.
I bought it from the actual aspect of their relationship.
Queensberry was enraged that wilder was distracting his son from his studies at
Oxford.
When Boise quit his studies in May of 1893 the marquee became determined to
bring wild down,
but it was around this time that wild finally achieved success on the stage or
woman of no importance,
so pins on April the 19th 1893 to widespread a claim during its run.
It brought him between 170 and 200 pounds per week is next play through satire.
An ideal husband was also successful providing the means for Oscar and Boise to
travel widely and live extravagantly.
The Marquis of Queensbury thought his son's failure to dig his degree in Oxford.
What was a scandalous waste of time?
He placed the blame squarely at the feet of wild,
referring it to the relationship as the most Lutherism and disgusting.
Queensberry began absolutely hounding the path.
He actually even threatened to disinherit by seat.
So this the son replied with a telegram.
What are they?
Funny Little Man.
You are Queensberry not surprising.
They didn't like this one bit.
Ends on the 19th of June.
Queensbury burst in on wild at is tied the street address in London.
He had a bodyguard with him.
Then it's proceeded to threaten bodily harm unless the relationship ended
immediately.
So what was Boise's reactions all of this?
Well,
he wrote nonchalantly to his father.
I write to inform you that I treat your absurd threats with absolute
indifference.
The encounter though,
it's unsettled.
Wild who got out of London for several months going on a holiday with his family
to where then this is where he works on his latest play,
the importance of being earnest,
but it wasn't before Boise,
unable to stay away,
invited himself along.
And as you might imagine,
this caused a little bit of tension between Mr and Mrs Wiles,
the importance of being earnest opens to great applause.
On February the 14th 1895 do weeks later.
It was already a wild success and in through Oscar Wilde's style,
he began basking in the glow of this.
It was at this that wild calls in at the lavish Albermarle club.
There he was handed a card from Queensbury by a port APP.
On this card was scrawled do Oscar Wilde posing sodomite.
That's Boise's urging wild when's a Margaret Street police station to ask for a
warrant for Queens.
Barry's arrest on the grounds of Lidl.
The case came to trial on April the third prosecuting counsel Leadwood Carson
and put on the stand a 16 year old boy who claimed had been paid for sex by
wiles.
Carson then went on to dissect works published by wild revealing.
They're supposed homosexual undertones,
so malady wilds reacts to this rather serious events.
Well,
he chose to wield his celebrated wit as his main defensive tool.
He was often funny,
but the implicit superiority in his position,
it was also damaging in one exchange when Carson asked whether the affection and
love that is portrayed in the picture of Dorian gray might lead an ordinary
individual to believe it had a sort of medical tendency.
Oscar replied,
I have no knowledge of the ordinary individual,
which didn't exactly inderam to anyone.
Wilds council and Edward Clarke,
we'll say,
made serious miscalculations that did his clients no favors.
He went over the letters of the Queensberry had sent his son in an attempt to
show how crazy the father had become to the jury.
Though queens breeze volatility was driven by a paternal regard for Boise's
character as Carson budget.
His clients had one hope alone and that was simply saving his son on the third
day of proceedings with things not exactly going brilliantly wild.
He chose not to attend.
This was to prove the most damaging day.
Yet with Carson announcing that he intended to introduce saying number of boys
who would testify to shocking acts performed by Oscar.
Now without consulting his clients.
While it's lie,
a Clark offered to abandon the case.
The defense,
however,
insisted that the original the stamps,
the judge agreed and compelled and acquittal from the jury Queensberry he was
found not guilty of libel.
Against wiles is it now been proven that is written.
Accusation of sodomy was not libelous,
but now there was another important consequence.
It left wild,
highly vulnerable to arrest for sodomy,
which was a crime at that time in England and well,
this is exactly what happens at five in the evening of the day,
the libel case was decided.
A summons was issued for the arrest of Oscar Wilde's.
The charge was committing acts of gross indecency hiding in the Catagen hotel.
Oscar was urged by Boise and others to take a boat immediately for France.
Even his wife told him to run.
However,
this just didn't sit right with whales.
He was determined to stand his ground and declaring,
I shall stay and do my sentence,
whatever it is.
At 6:10 PM do detectives arrived and to our case,
semi drunk wilds to both street station.
The arrest of Oscar Wilde caused an absolute sensation.
Any friends that he still has quickly drifted away,
both of is currently running place.
They were canceled and his name very quickly became toxic.
Wilder was captain a cell in both street,
which was that in Holloway prison,
Queensbury now administered the low blow or forcing a bankruptcy sale of Oscar's
belongings helped by a long list of angry creditors.
By this time,
wild was about $6,000 in debt after making sure that Oscar had nothing of any
physical value,
Queensberry wrote to a newspaper denying that he was capable of any sympathy for
wiles.
He stated I've helped to cut out then destroy shocks.
I have no sympathy for them,
but it felt sorry and wished to put them out of pain as fast as possible.
The trial,
well,
it ran from the 26th to the 29th of April.
It was extraordinarily explicit in its illusions to sexual acts.
Many coming from the young men who claimed to have been partakers various Savoy
hotel employees testified that they had seen boys in Wilde's bed.
However,
Oscar's council was able to point out the contradictions in testimonies,
especially those if the rent's boys.
This all meant that the jury,
they were unable to reach a verdict,
but wild he was not out of the woods as an almost immediate retrial began
between the two trials.
He did manage to secure a bale,
though stiffed conditions were imposed.
He tried to stay at a number of hotels.
I need to be told to teach that he was unwelcome.
You finally managed to find lodgings with his brother Willie.
The second trial.
It began on May the 20 seconds at the Old Bailey.
This time after two hours of discussion,
the jury returned with a verdict of guilty.
The sentence,
all it would be two years of hard labor.
Walter was taken to pens and Phil prison,
the woods in bed in his cell has sheets and rugs,
but no mattress at 10 parts was provided for his toilet.
The prison glades.
They were also not exactly his accustomed style of dress.
While it was also compelled to walk on a treadmill senselessly for six hours
each day until now to exercise outdoors for one hour.
He was also forced to make a postal bags for three whole months.
He had no outside contact and after that things were not much better with him
only being allowed to write one letter.
The regime was absolutely brutal.
Wildrick calling three punishments authorized by law,
hunger,
insomnia,
illness.
In September of 1895 he received a visit from Constance who found the experience
awful more so than any conception of it could be.
Constance report it that wilds professed a rejection of his former conduct and
begged her for forgiveness for his madness during the last three years.
She decided to stands by her week rather than wicked spouse.
Still she abandoned his name referring to herself as constants.
Holland.
When Boise heard about Oscar is rejection of his form of lifestyle.
He was heartbroken.
He wrote,
I am not in prison,
but I think I suffer as much as Oscar and in fact more.
That was probably not the case though because I mean prison.
It was obviously pretty rough.
In October,
he actually came down with dysentery.
Then on November the 21st he was transferred to Redding prison as Clapham
junction station.
He was spat on and ridiculed by the crowds.
Here are the conditions.
They were improved,
I just duties they were lighter.
He was finally released.
On May the 19th 1896 Oscar was booked into the hotel sandwich in d app in
northern France,
living off the generosity of the few friends who had stood by him.
By now,
constants had designed it on divorce and suffering herself with spinal
paralysis,
had put it off any reunion.
Between June and July of 1897 Oscar wrote his last major work,
the ballad of reading the subjects as well that was underlining the need for
reform in Britain's prison and justice systems like in the APP.
It was excruciatingly lonely for Oscar society at large.
Shuns him and he spent day after day alone and miserable.
Finally has resolved,
collapsed hymns.
He wrote to Boise inviting him to come and stay.
They reconciled on August the 28th with wild bursting into tears at the site of
his one true love.
When Constance heard of her husband's behavior,
she wrote to him up for bidding and he return to your filthy insane life.
When he refused to give our Boise,
she cut him off completely.
Once the initial passion subsided,
it became clear that to both wild and Boise were different than their pretrial
selves.
Boise,
he felt a duty to help wild but this was no longer tied to love.
On December the third Boise left for Naples and did not return Oscar's last two
years,
mostly in Paris.
They were pitiful.
He drank hired men and bagged acquaintances.
They were few constants.
Oland sadly died at age 40 after an operation on her back on April the seventh
80 98 then in April,
1900 wild went with an acquaintance named Harold matters to Rome where he
received the pope's blessing.
A month later he was in Paris and suffering from ill health,
which he attributed to food poisoning.
His skin was irritable and then frequently came out in rashes.
By September.
It was completely bed ridden on October the 10th it was operated on for an ear
infection.
The operation,
it did not go well and he got worse still.
He did insist on continuing to drink absent fan champagne,
I'll November the 25th they diagnosis of acute inoperable cerebral meningitis
was reached from here on,
Oscar drifted in and out of consciousness and even sanity at half past five the
following morning at death rattle began minutes after his demise,
his body actually sort of exploded.
Fluid pouring out of several RF assists.
Oscar Wilde's,
well he died as he had lived in appropriately,
outrageously and with scans reference to watch decorum demanded.
So I really hope you found that video interesting.
If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below and do not forget to subscribe for
brand new videos every Monday and Thursday.
We've got loads of other people just like this.
Also check out a couple of videos from the archives over there on the race and
does it always.
Thank you for watching.
Hello again.
Just jumping in real quick to add something.
Now that that video was over.
Obviously this is recorded later.
We want to get your opinion on something.
We've made some tee shirts that go along with this video.
We're thinking about doing it for other biographics that we put together.
Please do check out the link in the description below.
We've got some t shirts with Oscar Wilde,
quotes on them.
Do check it out.
Let us know what you think in the comments.
We'd love to hear from you and whether you'd like to see more.
Stuff like that.
And again,
thanks for watching.